all right we are back with our real
thoughts a new day in the mayor new day
night or apocalypse are upside down I
think we're in the upside down you're on
the upside I think without even
realizing I think we're wearing
appropriate shirts no no this was
intentional I I felt it was the best way
to go so um yeah just business is
judicial for us
I like create a safe space well we'll
still make political jokes here there
but I just want a place for you to go
and be happy we are we're still on the
air
yeah for now now so we're not in V for
Vendetta territory ed where the
gestapo-like punches us in the face it
says who's laughing now funny man
so okay whatever enough of this darkness
what are we doing actually you know the
more I think about it I want to say I
got this from a someone a convention
recommended this and I was like Oh
that'd be good I can't believe even
talked about and then after everything
has happened like and Jesus is kind of a
perfect movie to talk about an
interesting one ah let's talk about
patch Adams and I'm really interested oh
I hate this movie - it is Drake's Estero
is best role I always forget you
probably had a much bigger seat into the
room just is so and everybody's public
consciousness or like that you know that
mind when you think of Greg's sister but
I always forget about bad Adam yeah yes
there's little far as no lines right but
he originally had lines but no I think
this is an interesting movie to talk
about because the ideas behind the real
person are quite fascinating and maybe
it's this was a common problem with God
rest his soul Robin Williams's films I
love Robin Williams like he's a great
comedian like it's not a judgment on him
but the movies he chose always had a
great
message and I love it I appreciate that
I have no problem with the message but
the way they're done it's so hokey
maltese malti music ladies they're very
high lahic and yeah I kind of feel if
you really want these kind of message
there's amazing Good Will Hunting is one
of his best films because it's the same
kind of like message of overcoming
difficulties but it it lacks that kind
of like it doesn't feel as manufacturer
like a home like I feel like Robin
Williams we was almost like Hallmark
card films yeah mark movies like well
when he was in the just movie then you
go through sort the bad mood do you like
you know one hour photo insomnia death
to smoochy and stuff that's a complete
nothing I'm not counting those back they
were mostly inspirational stuff people
go into the whoa but that was a post
Good Will Hunting phase like I feel like
somehow with that film you got into this
kind of like oh I can stretch myself and
do these things I thought it was very
interesting I'm not saying all of those
darker films he did are great but I
certainly think they're interesting I
would watch them way more than I ever
would patch Adams
I don't like death to smoochy but go
ahead leave watch that burn place that
there is a phase where everything every
Robin Williams film you saw with the
exception of hook which was nice because
you know even though it's not a perfect
film its its own thing but almost every
Robin Williams whom we saw was either
good morning Vietnam or Dead Poets
Society or both yeah and this definitely
falls into that category
and but what's so interesting about is
that doing this movie forced me to do
research on the real guy
what's nothing like Robin Williams it's
quite a giant eye I mean this guy he
looks like if Edwin was still alive I
grew this Mark Twain mustache yeah I
like just this big goofy guy but he is
uh he looks like some sort of performer
at a theme park yeah
but doing a magic show we're just kind
of what he does but his idea was that
hospital should be very positive places
and that the more positive energy there
is a
you the better you'll feel and the
faster you'll recover it can even help
save lives and I'm not against that
honestly when you here really sit down
talk about it's like this is fascinating
and he himself is not a fan of the movie
you know he tried to promote I came out
like more shooting happens but he didn't
like the film and he said a big part of
it is that you know they focus on one
thing they focus on the clown element
he's like that's not all there is
there's a lot more to it there's a lot
more to the comforting there's a lot
more to the medicine there's a lot more
to all this and of course the things
that we planted in the review like there
was no love interest and it was a guy
that died you know and it was the best
friend yeah we made us so long which
apparently they're kind of you said he
said his friend would have just laughed
at ya and now I'm gonna love in chess
and stuff like apparently this guy had a
really good sense of humor so it makes
me feel a little better but it's still
like what the hell movie that's awful
oh no what in it in a dumb way I almost
forgive those gross historical
inaccuracies because I don't think it
affects the message as much what does
bother the fuck out of me is that seeing
where it's just like haha I'm gonna
steal all the materials from the
hospital I'm like yeah that was just
like and I just I remember staring at
that going I'm like I will bet you a
million dollars patching the real patch
Adams every day there's a goofy way yeah
burn up and everything he's got an actor
with it yeah and I and the movie plays
this as a comedic moment and I'm like no
that's something a psychopath does but
that's robbing Peter to pay Paul like
I'm just gonna take out of this hospital
i Q no it's just magically replaced
instantly like nobody's gonna be like
fuck happened to us as we all girls like
hospitals are so well funded they have
said so many doctors I mean come on and
that man the pisses Milkha's he's a
doctor at the Bobby
you know that blew my mind I ever I have
a hard time you know so that that one
that one scene pissed me off the most
and then you know the the friend thing
changing to a woman I love interest is
dumb it's it's screenwriting cliches 101
if you ever want to teach a class and
how not to write a screenplay patch
Adams is a great example you know the
other cliche that drove me nuts because
I'm like yeah I'm sure patch Adam set on
a cliff and the butterfly floated up to
him and he reached up into the sky and
the music swelled and I'm just fuckin s
you know I just realized something uh
yeah you wouldn't be able to do this
because I think hey to me people like
the movie and B to me people would
connect it to Robin Williams doing with
this passing and everything but wouldn't
this be a fascinating remake what if
they remade this more like what the real
person was oh I'd kill it I'd kill to
see that I'd killed to see that because
if you did like I'm gonna say Oscar bait
style where we're gonna go for kind of a
quasi historical movie that examines the
real person and what happened like
imitation game or something which has
its own cliches and stuff but the more
serious along those lines like yeah
these are the real issues behind like
here's pros and cons and this is what he
did and you know these are some of the
benefits and maybe this is what he was
up against but you know what that's part
of my problem is I understand because
there was pushback at the time even when
the film was released from some doctors
who were just like you know we shouldn't
we shouldn't have to be clowns and and
this and that you know but I don't think
that was his point is that hospitals
need to be a little more inviting and
the funny thing is since then I've seen
that like I've seen hospitals that have
the money you know that's a big issue
particularly in this country but the
hospitals that you know have the money
to do that rich hospitals have tried to
go for more of a forest II feel and open
and not the same just plain white color
yeah and you know the kids wards have
like you know painted murals like so
I feel though that the villain like is
so cartoonishly over the top that you
get a sound to that level
those measly would make us like a big
get a big duck days out of yeah I yeah
they're like the whole stand again huh
you know it's it you know what it is
it's uh he's more like a character out
of Jaws like you're gonna be so nice
like he was so cartoonishly evil that it
sucked any reality out of it for me I'm
just like I'm like okay like this is a
little much and I start to then question
the other side which I kind of agree
with which is that we need to treat the
body as a whole mind body and spirit and
it can't just be about only the body
because they've proven this like if
you're unhappy clinically depressed all
these other things and miserable
you're not gonna heal as fast so but
that's a great argument and it's all
sucked out of it I can't take it
seriously because it's just showing this
in such a cartoony way than like well
now you're making me question what
you're calling the positive side of this
because I just can't believe how
ridiculous this is like and it's like
these Christian exploitation films like
where the Atheist is so ridiculously
evil or something thank you that to us
the kind of thing of those Christian
it's like a movie Brad Jones winter view
this is this is the doctor well yeah
that that doctor is the Kevin Sorbo yeah
but yeah I was just thinking of that
because you know a lot of these
Christian movies I mean you know we were
raised in you know Roman Catholic and
stuff you know we're not anti religion
or anything so that we know a lot of
these films have you know they're coming
from a place that kind of wants to do
good but then it's sort of being
manipulated in a way and it's our
blackened and poisoned and it's turned
into science actually gonna do more harm
and it's one of those things where it's
like I think we do have that card to
yeah that's one of the reasons why it's
so hard now you know I think they can't
talk about this movie because this movie
does want to play paint the very
black-and-white
you know good guy bad guy thing in a
time where a lot of people want to do
that really hardcore right now and
that's kinda what got us here to begin
with but then I D just become passive or
whatever and it's one of those things
where it's like it doesn't it's is with
this film you do not need to do that and
I think it hurts it when you do that
because there's some interesting ideas
that come from a place that seems very
simple but it can get lost so easily you
need an interesting complicated way to
show its display to show it's just so
dumb it's a fucking hospital there's no
good guys and bad guys this is guys you
know and I know doctors can be smug and
have terrible bedside manners but you
know at the end of the day they still
have an interest in curing you like it's
just it just went so over the top of it
that I'm just like why is this
cowboys-and-indians all of a sudden what
a night cowboys and Native Americans
tumbling but I think there's something
to yeah I sort of look at this and I see
them going you know back and forth
between like you know we need to do
something to help the kid we need to do
something to you know to these poor
patients and stuff and and the weather
the bits I'm in or like you said which I
found out Banshee is one of the few
things that got right they actually did
not have very good bedside manner back
then program hearing I bet I don't know
but that there's some factors that still
don't these come in there's like yeah do
this we do then that's something again
that's the fault of this movie is that
because it's so cartoonish that when you
get to something that is correct you
have a hard time believing it it doesn't
create a world where it feels believable
and I think that really hurts what could
be a great message and some really great
ideas you can look the dude up you know
he's actually trying to put together I
think he called it aha Hospital I think
where he wants it to be sort of like
this very positive upbeat place and he
wants to see if that will help people
get better faster so and I think I think
you could I don't think like he says
being a clown isn't everything you gotta
know your medicine you have to treat
every patient you know a little
differently you have to be
man you have to be trained in that movie
I never got the sense that he was even a
doctor he's annoying the other doctor
was Robin Williams and I'm not throwing
all of that I'm Robin Williams cuz if
the script doesn't give him any scenes
where he's really doctoring what are you
supposed to do like but yeah I just came
out I was like wait to see more like a
clown than a doctor to me and I would
imagine that to get through Medical
School you have to know something so and
one of the few performances in this film
where I was really like man is this guy
just doing his all with a part that's
really nothing Philip Seymour Hoffman in
this another God rest doesn't manage so
many dead people there's more think
about um buzz this year alone but you
know with the with him in this you know
he has a scene where he's like I said
that you were cheating because how can
you possibly do this how can you i study
three times as much as you do and you
barely open a book in stain you possibly
pass this how can you possibly do this
well and it's never explained yeah yeah
you know where it's like that wasn't
because he had to hear a brilliant mind
there are people for who some things
come easier but the way the films were
trained and I'm like no philip Seymour
Hoffman's right we never do see him ever
like so in prophecies and then what the
movie sees them yeah he's got to see how
he does this you know I know like if he
does pick up things very fast could be
look I never explained that it's never
looked into just yeah he just was such a
prick I just I just wanted to slap him
across the face and I'm like that
shouldn't happen and I like Robin
Williams to I don't want to slap around
my wings across the face but this movie
just did nobody any favours well that's
kind of like we talked about with like
this old environmental films like Fern
Gully and stuff like that where it's
like they're doing such a terrible job
with what's supposed to be a good
message they just when I want to
retaliate against that message you just
want to Club a baby seal yes I have
never wanted to destroy so much Arctic
Wildlife and after
episode of Captain Planet and I have no
idea I don't know I mean you say patch
Adams people know what it is I mean they
know that based on true stories arrived
only in film so I mean hopefully it did
some good but I feel like this could
have been like explosive event when you
go really we got pushback I remember in
the comment section so people were just
like I don't get it why it's it's a good
message that I'm like separate that from
execution because I'm not arguing that
patch Adams you know or some of the
messages behind it are bad marketing
that the execution sucked they're two
different things saying oh well that's
bad what he wanted to do like well some
things that movie were bad because they
didn't even really happen but you know
so what and I'm remembering like we're
talking about the cartoonish bad guy and
he has a line I really remember he says
you know you're a man of a brilliant
mind and like most brilliant men you
feel the rules don't apply to you and I
thought that's actually kind of a
fascinating line because there are a lot
of like and that can be kind of a good
thing or a bad thing we don't but it was
this awareness that he this is a person
who's brilliant but you need to kind of
play by our rules take a step back and
stuff and I thought maybe this will be
an interesting person but no they just
turned into a cartoon character and
that's such a shame because would have
been interesting to see these two minds
that think very differently but are very
capable and Irbil very brilliant kind of
butting heads and trying to figure this
out that would have been really
fascinating nope yeah he's just being
greedy so it's what your loser McFly
yeah it's like just all those classics
yeah I thought that principle was more
realistic I've no principles like that
yeah and then the fucking ending with
the kind of course you need a courtroom
cement room could that's the shays 101
make sure it ends somehow in a courtroom
make sure there's an oppressor ational
speech the sappy music plays
yeah and then a you know my favorite if
you want a good time go type in Roger
Ebert's review hatch Adams it's one of a
Bert's best and the way he ends it it
just just plays up the ridiculousness of
it then how sappy it isn't how could a
he's like and wouldn't you know it's
dear reader the children marching with
little claws like that the sarcasm
dripping from it but actually both I
forgive that's when the school is going
through like you know the illness and
stuff but I remember he really hated it
his written review was very funny
hospitals yeah well I want to say the
the TV show review was pretty funny too
but I can't remember but I remember they
were both kind of having fun mocking
this film they're just kind of like oh
good like you're getting this - I want
to be sure it's not just me I'm not as
fun as Godzilla where they were
complaining that they didn't get eaten
by the monsters you are the greatest
ways to retaliate really I did I and I
love it when people troll and I'm just
like no let me show you how it's done
this is what you could have done and
you're gonna insult me let's go let's go
to work okay I'll help you out here yeah
you so uh yeah I'm trapped I would say
definitely go check out the real person
cuz I'm not gonna say you're gonna agree
with everything you know I'm not sure I
agree with everything either but it's
worth looking into it's definitely
something really one thing I don't think
anything on the planet should be called
a ha possible unless you're making a
horror movie set in a carnival or
something it's just hard carnival would
have a location like that and I'm sure
that's like part of it you're not
supposed to take it too seriously or
whatever but I'm like I'll go with you I
just feels like there's a better to
agree with anything but that's about
it's complicated issues
none of which are explored in this um so
uh okay before I go I actually forget
I forgot to show you this I think he's
taking his pants off folks when we did
our real thoughts of devil somehow we
got talking about I don't even know how
we got onto it but we got talking about
combining pokemons with Schindler's List
and call it P cos list and we kept going
well at the last convento is that
somebody actually put together a poster
for pikas yes it is and I just miss is
happening this bill bird eat your heart
gotta save them all ah yes yeah I just
had it and he went into the Academy
Award winner for Best Original Score
pokemons theme yep that's on there too
wait did he hold on let me see
oh no I I don't think you went in oh no
wait oh no they're they're actual like
German yeah I want to see like squirtle
okay 99% near flawless A+ I would have
just put the Pokemon names in here in
the list but this is very pretty damn
bright yet but that's amazing he had to
draw the Pokemon come on and the glove
over that over the names I need that -
did you where dude were critics yeah
that's true we got a problem
yeah no he showed me that I'm just like
oh dude we can laugh okay we can laugh
at the Holocaust the first one yeah
okay I supposed to be happy spot happy
fun this will be a hospital I think a
lot of us we go into the hot thanks for
you you know what baby it's not so crazy
AHA Hospital sounds wrinkly dad is there
booze involved i man so wait that's it
I definitely go check that out I guess
it's just it's an interesting read it's
a very very nosy but you know what yes
the movie yes so um yeah guys that's
about it and we shall see you next time
we're all mad here
take care later